guys this is gonna be a super special
video because it is a compilation video
of the past ten years of my experiences
on making videos with the iPhone we're
celebrating the 10th anniversary of the
original iPhone and for me the iPhone
has been I don't even know it's been
life-changing a combination of the
iPhone and YouTube and all of the crazy
endeavors that I've got myself into on
the internet it's been a really long
road a lot of people think that these
things happen overnight
they don't I've been making youtube
videos for almost 11 years and that's
pretty crazy I loaded a book together
this video to look back on some fun and
fond memories that I've had with my
phone and waiting in lines and
shattering phones and we've been through
a lot these iPhones are not a lot of you
guys have been there since the beginning
so hello to all of the old hello to all
of the new viewers I appreciate all of
you and thank you for coming along on
such a crazy internet journey so 10
years of iPhone guys you excited yeah
very Toonami show you guys like I said
10 years of me and my iPhone but we're
gonna start from the newest videos and
we're gonna go to the old videos good
idea Edie yeah good idea where we were
we're where we are you barely are now
and then you guys will see where we came
from so this video will progressively
get way WAY worse and more cringy as we
go so I think it's uh it's pretty yeah
watching back how do you remember you
were I remember a lot now
there's a hole in my phone a screw he's
here he's here in all of his glory I
[Music]
just don't even want to touch it because
I'm gonna smudge it up so much already
here it is rose gold which is pink so
one of the newest features is the force
touch so you'll be able to peek in as
they said alright guys the day of the
iPhone 6s launched and puppy is not
coming with us
we're gonna leave you here you don't
want to come
is anybody here yet open up I'm ready
hello there we go huh look at you you
look so shiny gold compared to these
silver and we'll have a rose gold
comparison as soon as I get home with my
sister
anyway hold on a phone call on my iPhone
6 plus plus plus plus hello hi yeah it's
really good to hear from you and welcome
new iPhone is out so I probably should
sell my old one I was wondering do I
need to make an appointment to come in
because I've got to make an appointment
at the Genius Bar ok
oh my goodness I'm sorry I'm not from
here I just looked at apples okay thank
you like this is it like we're here
we're first
what's that Galaxy s5 which bigger
bigger erupts into our food problem
totally sharp our common why I've been
sleeping to your money and just look
three days no big deal
I know but I think I'm getting sick now
that's not fun
[Applause]
got his phone Cody got a song whoa
bye Cody will talk to you soon
a pig
all right that's really good it is
really a mess tears to my face
there's an old
we're heading up an iPhone 6 pre-orders
RT will be back they say the apple is
right I don't know
okay the midnight midnight is midnight
should we were fire it says not to
refresh because I think we're in line
choose the model silver just wasn't the
Apple store woke up at like 2 o'clock in
the morning to be one of the first dish
sort of in line because I saw yesterday
there's about 40 people in line at 10
o'clock p.m. yesterday in line for their
iPhones just got in line last night
I can't see your face but I know it's C
I want this to be me man the iPhone 5s
in slate gray the survey that I did was
absolutely overwhelming for the amount
of goals for the gold phone which
hopefully I'll be able to get soon but
this is this light gray it is in fact
quite slate as you can tell it's like it
almost looks kind of like the silver
this is not gold so that gold it doesn't
even look gold almost the same color as
this silver and it should be already
activated and ready to go because I did
activate it in store dusting slowly
waiting for the moment process here as
she is very disappointed
able to get they have a white hair that
you really want to live my web search
turn this on oh my gosh
it will it really works ready well dive
into these folders here is my apple
folder and this is my camera folder
Safari Facebook group me Foursquare ways
fancy MyFitnessPal which I probably
should use a little more often
path Pinterest Instagram YouTube
WordPress from a blog turf pages pose
with it's not for you with full message
agenda its home or Christmas present if
it's a bring rain rain rain rain three
very fetching work to the pharmacy CCCP
things on so you guys might first notice
about the iPad Mini is much much much
much much smaller let's start it up so I
was just starting up him to do a size
comparison to the iPod - so here's the
iPad 2 and there's an iPad Mini as you
can tell is significantly smaller I'm
actually quite surprised I found my old
iPhone and when I turn it on this is
what happens nothing
please work I really want to use you I
want to get all the pictures and
whatever else is on here I want to get
it off of here I may have to take it to
the Genius Bar
today is September 21st 2012 -
hello yay the day of the iPhone 5 and I
just got mine in the mail so excited old
John new bells let's take it out look it
up shall we
new dome hello we're gonna open it it is
beautiful
shining shimmering splendid hey Siri are
you better than you were before
I'm sorry I'm afraid I can't answer that
see his box good luck
good luck you may notice that there's
nothing in it his box was delivered with
nothing in it do it was supposed to be
in it - for us I can transfer you to a
live agent let's make sure I wrote your
call correctly please tell me your
reason for calling today because I
opened up my UPS box it was supposed to
have my new iPhone 4s and there was
nothing in it it's gone ok I can come
right over to someone who can help me we
go why you know send me Oh
[Music]
or in the car the iPhone for Breanna's
with me hi
it is 627 am I can promise you that I
will never be the first person in line
for any sort of a beloved
way miss Brianne look how excited she is
to be here she had t-shirts for itself
look how excited she is I'm in line for
the after 5:00 so you guys didn't get it
since I'm in London one coming out next
year Geo
[Music]
okay launch day and I work my phone a
lot you didn't get one here I didn't get
one yet I figured I was going to wait
you can use you to build anyway it's an
to thing that's the take 48 hours for
activations humans sure pretty easily
here and I put an alibi Cuba then he's
like we can't but Anita today and I did
this without hacking or jailbreaking my
iPhone it's extremely easy to use so all
you have to do is download this 99-cent
app it's called frosty place now once
you have it downloaded and installed
click on it click Japanese and you'll
get that emoji option that you want to
click to on
[Music]
hi friends so I'm here at the Apple
Store okay I just want to let you know
that finally officially on front have an
iPhone also this current point in time
I also have three iPhones this one's
going back to 1800 minute your call is
important to us so please all the line
and an Apple representative will provide
assistance no we don't sold out saying
no we're sold out tonight we are all out
stop they had earlier we actually just
recently ran out now we sold out today
we ran out around three o'clock we are
sold already
[Music]
it's alright yeah but still I think I
think
[Music]
it's a long tie this line just
and I had to switch to 18t okay that's
wonderful well I got my first 18d bill
right here
in a box
[Music]
standing right in front of the iPhone
the iPhone the iPhone I'm drooling a
little bit it's gonna be spinning around
shortly and you'll be able to sit in
front of it
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this video it was kind
of crazy to look back and see how much
things have changed myself the internet
the entire landscape of digital media
has all changed so much and I'm so
excited for the future so I will see you
guys there and I'm gonna stop filming
about bye there it is
every white howlite channel we're gonna
have so many of the same vlogs there's
gonna be like 70 can we get closer to
see one on the lawn anyway this is at
least a picture we're trying